drink a tea spoon of soya sauce the only
reason why I can't do that beer all
these a lot there you heard about the
conjunction ting whatever's going on
nope it's lumpy my brother's don't eat
crumpets Wow it should buy an LV general
lump it's lump it my brother's don't eat
crumpets your matter team set already
I'm so gassed welcome to my new show on
standout TV alvey's hoof it wheel it
obviously right wing shock so it's got
started to lose wings maybe soon I don't
know I've got two contestants coming on
the show today
man that's buds no it is Lackey goes
into the miracle public areas chats
their man about site ml puts on a little
game then you've got miss fabulous you
just love and she's pretty and she's
just out there big bat regretting United
Food Fair anyway you understand football
let's just bounce I see wha-wha-what Gua
you're not saying to me gas yes and I'm
gassed yes yeah this is my game the
roulette full fitting blood
they're often fit roulette where do you
want Carly Picasa and I'm like yeah yeah
era one thanks for coming down
yeah we got yourself a slap in the face
you get stopped in the face but it's
long illness one two three four on the
board for is a mystery number so you
don't know what's going on before I'm
even going to tell you what's going on
before to it for has been mentioned you
get me when we reveal for you'll find
out what four is about okay so one
stands for you that's your position
that's your square protect it with your
life I don't like doing things not know
what I'm doing if you understand because
that makes me nervous so right now my
pants number to protect your corner of
as well free is meat and four is a
mysterious is it mysterious furious
alright mysterious one said that one
near is random I can ask you anything
off the bump so that for instance if I
said to you earlier I saw you looking at
a bum bum why are you doing that I was
staring ahead because it was a very huge
and very voluptuous and very a turn me
on not gonna like okay okay you happy
with that that's all you have to be
honest box and I like that's the honest
box am I looking forward to today yes I
I'm all about challenges I do challenges
in my past
spare time I like to just give girls
random dares lick my toes anyway before
I forget this here in the box is the
full Fitz so when it spins for instance
back there and it lands on you more or
less - you do not have to put your hands
in today
take her whatever is in there out a
question art so ever it is and you've
got a dutiful fit basically yep cool who
I think might struggle with the full
Fitz I'm not being sexist before I say
it
because I know he's at home now I don't
think mr. fabulous is ready for this
they think girls are weak but I'm here
for the girls that's four spots he's
used to eat in anything you know we done
a challenge before and and slugs snails
name it do a lot eat yes you know
spuds no allergies no illnesses you
didn't yeah rice pudding okay that's
fine we can work with that will change
it and mushrooms
okay mushrooms rice pudding my one spicy
food so anything spicy in the back do
not give it to me not on I use I didn't
say DUP and if it's spicy in the back or
he doesn't need it I'm built different
God took his time on me yeah seven days
he had four hours ex talk with men so I
feel LV and off have this they're gonna
struggle with this me will be al at work
lat breeze how we gonna start this then
what so I spin first what paper scissors
there's no way you doing it like that
what paper scissors in the middle yeah
what paper scissors at the data count of
three is who's great first year okay no
how do we do ting tang walla black
papers wave like okay cool cool
rock-paper-scissors
what paper scissors are I mean you know
no no I won all right you won map I
didn't I call what paper scissors yes
please
so now how's that worked in Sammy's your
first I'm second and she's fun cool
three and four okay guys funny
I should are two random question to you
and you have to answer it alright cool
well hey if you want a Chan
alright you want I'm nice but you and
all right you deity so happy faking yep
if use another world another dimension
yep
could you see yourself Marion getting
together with unlovely are fabulous
honestly honestly obviously that's
obviously bought other people first of
all she's beautiful she's national Kim I
like the phrase I like a smile your
teeth are very wet you've got nice
eyelashes as well your cheekbones look
great and everything but I don't think
we would click in that sense because my
personality I have a lot of women who
follow me you know and I wanna upset her
Jesus she looks I saw sonogram once and
she was wailing out about man and I said
you know what I gotta go down that road
she'll beat me up is it fair enough for
me to happen now it's a long why is it
so long why are you worried about how
long his feet is I put my head in a
man's foot artists embarrassing man huh
so you know even random people tend to
lick your feet bro that's it that's all
you're getting it use your feet smell a
bit sweaty that's a little [ __ ] but
that's cuz you have a long drive I don't
take it together well there you go
what's this a bow on number one gets to
the end the last person on your direct
message on Instagram saying what they
like I'll do that
Jimmy mDM's
first person in your direct message okay
stop fixing it
[Music]
the last person she said now go on you
have to do is not even the government in
the country so basically the last thing
that she said here was you from London
and be strong stay focused and pray and
if she says no love
okay no worries I was never with you I
[Laughter]
hope it's me getting to do sign to
someone else you know drink a teaspoon
of soy sauce soy sauce please
well sesame a teaspoon no yeah it can't
be that bad
[Laughter]
just some Chinese the only reason I
can't do that be rule these look that
you heard about the conjunction ting
whatever's going on you suspect me to
put this to make the chicken every
Chinese shop I've been in I saw this on
the side back it's an itch up in a
corner in hood and I suppose
and over there help me change this one
actually says eat a chili man man's
gonna eat a scotch funny if we replayed
to the front when he said I don't want
spicy food do you see how is the beach
no allergies no illnesses my one spicy
food so anything spicy in the back do
you not give it to me no no no use I
didn't say de anything spicy in the back
oh he doesn't need it but you'll have to
eat the whole finger hopefully roll I've
never done this in my life
I don't recall we're gonna survive this
you know you drunk
[Laughter]
yeah
[Applause]
Oh give me some more time
drain it's coming from everywhere I'm
lettin Rodimus or every I mean it was on
there we need to start from where look
if it stays on it is where is if it
lands on free off you wouldn't like that
yeah it can't be impossible to
you did you eat beware I'm the host I'm
gonna start with my foot down
proper spin I'm in pain money well I'm
gonna be open without a whole new
paragraph ring someone or the other
contestants trace and simply say it's
done what there's blood everywhere and
then hang on
do I get to choose who all fabulous Wow
you mean a fall and blood Easter bring
anyone he wants and tell them that what
Wow as if you digged it out
I'm praying what's that one of course
that is now all I know you had a
respected youtuber u76 bro you sound
like you're having sex is just blood
everywhere you can't ask me though of
course yes against walls about the most
craziest kinkiest Wow seriously burger
don't you stop bending up to herself
flat across she's thinking of bed it's
Benny still wanna say it a freak
what what color is Eve don't mind me
asking ok you could have been German
anyone could've been a [ __ ] to Spain
what is no but you Oh
that is if I go physically to let a man
eat a bottom hold always man that yeah
she liked it it's like she spins it for
me bold roll yes one of your poets
Nietzsche a dog treat
can I get to pick only one do the abyss
get is that right yeah thank you are
numerous between these two mouths
actually got a flippin old dog tree just
that over crackers
your teeth is built for that Pharaoh the
Jacob tracklist let me try alright we're
down to one more in the car
there's satin about the spins blood why
me the last guy man saying this is this
game sabotaged man oh my god so
embarrassing bride the best loss you
know he already knows what it is before
I even [ __ ] say it
I've got to do the cinnamon challenge
yeah you know we're so baby I know it's
gonna come back to haunt me
this is not gonna go well he's not
knitting no no put that in your mouth no
I'm putting it in the show let me
swallow yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
so when you just sitting there blah
let's do it got a building yes so thanks
for watching the show thanks for you
guys for coming on thank you we got wing
we got wind went over well
nope it's lumpy my brother's don't eat
crumpets